So, I'm now in a game.
And I'm ready to get started...
But first we need to make our character.
So the first choice is:
Male or Female?
[Mark is now processing...]
Which one would have me better chance to survive?
Since no one is independent on strength, I'm gonna go with...
The most...
MANLY
I possibly ca-
Actually no, I'm gonna make uh-
I'm gonna make a recreation of who I am
And I appreciate the pure DoomGuy-esque nature of this dude.
Ummm...
So, as far as I am...
And what I am...
I got a neck the size of a
*giggling* Greek...gawd
ugh
*more giggling* long like my- *wipes tears away* long, like my will to survive
*still being a giggly bitch* broad... narrow chest
*still giggling*
ah
some impinged shol-durrs
*what was that mark?*
some, ugh I like to call them arrow dynamic sholders
I cant stop staring at that neck, man
upper face size
[mark chuckling]
oh man
that is too funny
Jesus Christ
alright so, all the features Im picking are supposed to perfectly replication of me
and who I am, and all of you
I know, I know every single one of you out there
is standing with my thicccc neccc
can you even see a difference, between the two of us?
NO, you can not it is impossible
with my arrow dynamic shoulders
and my arrow dynamic neck
I will do whatever it takes to survive
ha head width
crank that shit
head height enormous, head depth don't even know what that means, oh
[mark chuckling]
all of my neck is dedicated to keeping my head aloft
in proper surviving position
hips
nope
narrow, nice!
svelte I might say
ok, torso height
I think, I think, I think I got a nice shh
I think I got a nice, a nice compact torso, yeah?
oh
whoa
*mark chuckling*
nice and compact. yeah really assentuates the ugh
the bewbs there
alright torso depth, be concave be concave I think, nah
lets make that good, alright leg length
well that's
*markimoo does himself a giggle*
that's more true to life, huh?
That's more true to life
Let's make the torso a little bit taller
that's  good this is going well arms hands
huge upper legs massive
lower legs not as big, foot giant
arm length *homemade sound fx* ok
arm length epic upper arm bulging, whoa
not that bulging, eh.  *does himself another giggle*
lower arm big, okay Popeye get that big under
control there, that's more-  well it's not natural
but woo legs, oh those buns oh the
sweet thighs *giggling at thunder thigh Popeye*
see I'm gonna save this, can I save this as uh... TRUE Mark
that's what he is. all right there's no
changing for hair, just haircolor y-yeah let's go
good they don't have a red option
don't need that with brown there we go
alright Survivor name? Mark... iplier
spawn region
I don't know south zone 2 whatever that is
I'm just gonna go with that one no oh god damn
good thing i saved it
i'm a smarty alright there we go great
new survivor i am the real markiplier
whoever wants to try to kill me please
do your best. oh
whoa, hey nice scritchy- scratch
man that itches like crazy. well here I am
world it's time for you to accept who i
am and understand that me...am ready to
surv- oh, is that a bird i'ma kill you
oh is that a dodo I'm gonna punch to shit out
of you you didn't even want to drive
oh shit puttin' up a fight huh?
whoa... *confused* the fuck?
*more homemade sound fx*
yeah you think you can, you think you can get
away without me whumpin' some butt-age? Whoa
stop rubber bandin' all over the place
don't even try
that's right, oh is that dead?
I thought so
gender female mate boosted I killed a
level 110 dodo you think anything in
this world is going to stop me when
I can kill a dodo of level 110 with my bare fffists
I don't think so, oh its unconscious
okay well suppose I better eat it
well alright
this feels wrong, but I'm 'on keep doing it
maybe I'll level up
I did level up I didn't even know
leveling up was a thing that could
happen i'm going, oh. okay then I guess
I'll take that I think what the hell is
all this what is- i don't know what all
this is...ah
can I get some meat off of this?
i guess it has no meat there was literally no
point in murdering that dodo I should
have done better
well i'm off to a bad start this now I'm
gonna do this
oh hey all right then just gonna need
change one option that one note that can
go please
right then well now that I've shared
something
oh is that a fellow survivor don't trust
him
I'm just a little where's my my how do i
had only talked people that's important
to know I push-to-talk be what's the
frequency I defecated why did I
implicate didn't press add
ok anyway so i need to get through here
hey Bob apparently lives here so what I
need to do is I need to make my way
inland excess inventory to apply it
Oh shooty Oh ok alright I don't love up
whoo that's how I love a lot oh hell
yeah you know what I'm gonna level up as
amazingly a good level hundred and ten
you think anything's gonna stop me
yes absolutely i don't know how many
points do I have I don't even see that
stamina up
what is that I don't know hi I don't
know I don't know I have no idea what
this is I need to learn that when the
brain
I don't know what I've got
ingram points it was costumes mean I
don't Parker know okay you know what I
level up that's all that matters i'm
going to England because I got survive
i'm going to England I'm going inland
who I can't okay there we go
man that's dinos around here see the
thing I've never played this game
I've only watch someone play it once and
I believe those Ross so what I'm going
into this
find it doesn't even begin to describe
the kind of blind that i am also how do
i craft over what is that what is with
that there's a rap next to a giant
floating obelisk in the sky if there's
some sort of wealth inequality here I
can see it plain as day is bullshit also
what's with the weird glowing also it
was weird breaking in this guy never
seen that before
don't worry i'm going to live allowed my
life little I'm going to level out I'm a
little out of my life here in the woods
that country called hell yeah I can give
you get fuckin would you pitch you think
it's going to stand up for my fence to
the hopes for you read the answer is
noted in the world I punch to tree down
all about
yeah I am better than I thought I was
man i'm just getting something paying
back the world for what it's done to
meet it goes something it's supposed to
be
apparently been turning my help you know
what I don't care
going to make me tougher in the long run
alright so let's see what I can make
with this match when craftable who I
could use that I needed stone where do i
get a stone and probably from punching a
rock
yeah yeah that's not a punchable rock
and it's a collectible rock man how do i
get an appropriate is it's a collectible
often
yeah okay all right i need to stop
present after that when i got this and
me markiplier and make a pickaxe craft
it
oh hell yeah I'm cracking it up you
think I can craft I know exactly the
craft I'm the craftiest son of a ship
never did walk with arc land
oh and i'm done was talking too much
didn't even know I was done but hey look
at this
I've got me a fork install google search
for ya on the best survivor that ever
could walk this world
I'm the best survivor to ever know
anything this landed there's one thing
that I do know it's not a lot if I am
master of the environment that I've been
put in
why am I still talking our even know
anymore all i know this rock is my
almost back to see your nose
Brock until our bird the google gobble
of a bird I defecated well I mean that's
another point to make in a different
world although you think you can mess
with me wild female doke want to beat
the shit out of you
oh you think you can map my stone pic
knows no fury you think mercy is in my
vocabulary when leveling up is it shake
you will die and you will need to keep
my feeling on your skin
don't don't run for me don't know why I
know where you live
I can find you I'll shit all over your
life you go your friend because she can
run down
you thought I would forget you think i
was for him barely actually get some
water i'm gonna take it from your blood
and pour over number but I got some lint
from the apparently i don't know how or
why he hungry
hell yeah killed dodo did it get some
meat from a time i'm really only got to
be a way to get me to the right I gotta
be did I get anything from at do they
get anything from that I gotta hide that
doesn't help me at all but i need
apparently i need to make some more
stone pics
why am I in pain huh why my in pain well
maintained from because the cold and
hungry who will be a bitch right so I
got to find a way to get food somehow or
else I'm gonna die with computers all
right what do we got here
Suns going down to find huge for too
late
photo no I'm gonna leave you merciful
again
shit can I just see I must be getting
delirious because i'm seeing visions in
the distance and i don't like it i gotta
find something that I can kill and then
each because this ain't working for me
and watching and I killed oh yeah I'm
gonna kill you just because I got
nothing better to do and hopefully i'll
be able to get the meat out of you
I'm sorry I'm killed two of you already
I'm other tasted blood and I just can't
be stopped
I'm a literal monster assemble the dough
police and catch me
I want to be caught broke ok alright
lawmaker I I got another one so that
that's good alright don't worry my
burger weapon is back if you think that
it was / is not the nightmare continues
you're gonna die okay three rami's there
we go finally
yes Ronnie what happened last meet was
trying to get me this whole time I
wasn't giving me walk
I gotta get some alright so let's make a
tour
who yes please my health is going down
I don't know learning groups ok
oh I have to do these oh this makes so
much more all that makes so much more
sense
oh hell yeah ok so that was important so
now i need to who
things are going very badly for me I
keep pressing tab i gotta change that
you don't have much time okay crap that
crap that ok man i am in bad shape boy
ok who that sounds awful i don't like
the sound of that at all
ok this there this they're all right
okay but this down
oh my god don't die please please don't
die
oh we got my god i would light it light
fire
what am i dying of what am i dying up
well I see in color a few vision boy i'm
not doing well i have a broken bone have
a broken bonus have a broken bone
whatever broken bonus bullshit i don't
know what i did i don't know how to fix
it
I
cooked meat here i'm gonna eat that
quickly as I can
Oh how's it going back on oh maybe my
broken bones couldn't mend itself done
out because i was indeed starving i
might have been starving might event but
that's not for me to decide I think I
think I think starving a bit of us I
think starting a bit of a rough way to
say about things I think I'm doing
pretty good need fiber so where do i get
fiber I don't get fiber I need more
fiber in my life how do i get fiber so I
got to access options yet
okay well can see and attend all right i
got torch imma put it there
look I'm scared of the dark quick with
darn old in their little boy don't you
need i knows me Dino doodoo oh yeah i'm
just going to swell wildly I'm down I'm
doing more
alright i'm getting worried parents are
carriers and I'm gonna go back in
camping to eat some food cause I'm
starving again album count crown much
room do I need I mean I know my neck
needs a lot of sustenance but this is
ridiculous there a god damn diculous
give me my charcoal I don't know what
that's going to cook beat sure I'll take
it
girl your mom alright we're going to
actually do something for me
second actually do something for me past
you gotta let me be your left BB ass
alright fine without fucking back
what is that what is that some sort of
like this floating and guy that's a
weird single-color moon
what are you an ocean are you mocking me
for bringing one at that
what is that I'm gonna find out what
that is but I don't know yet i will get
their butts bearing with me are cracked
so amazingly amazingly I'm not dead yet
which is incredible i don't know how
that happened when I'm not dead so i'm
gonna take this as a win and I'm gonna
end this episode here while I'm still
alive and then carry on to another one
because the survival
does not stop in a single episode of Arc
I'm gonna carry on for a long time i'm
an old this island and I'm gonna do that
through negotiating skills with all the
other players here i'm a smooth-talking
just loving me
sure all my all chat just hasn't been on
this whole time because that people have
a near me blabbing about it to myself
but I think they're gonna come to
respect the great and powerful
markiplier when he comes down here and
they seem to be busy talking about real
life stuff over honestly who cares but
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you for believing in me
there's a lot more less than this silent
to take care of dog get to that very
soon so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always else to you in
the next video